Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 3rd,
2018 what's going on?
How are you?
How are you doing?
Oh,
I hope you're doing better than I'm doing Jesus Christ.
I'm in New York City right now.
I don't think I've ever been lonelier the in my fucking life.
Good Lord.
It's just like,
you know,
I don't know anybody in this city anyway.
I used to fucking know everybody.
I don't fucking know anybody
looking for a familiar face.
It's crazy.
I'll tell you this city when you have 50 versus when you're 25 is completely
different.
So if there's anybody in that twenties living in New York,
and I know you got a Shitty fucking living situation like most people,
but uh,
that shit time do,
did she or city,
so fuck it.
Enjoy it.
Jesus Christ.
First of all,
it's December 3rd and I'm like,
oh,
Christmas in New York is exciting.
You know,
I love the holidays and Shit,
you know,
and I'd come here and it's fucking,
it's colder in La than it is in New York.
I don't,
you know,
this whole new fucking a post mi two era,
whether,
yeah,
I'm bleeding,
blamed the me too movement on a global warming,
that's my next fucking brilliant move in my career.
Um,
so I went down and I did a set tonight at the cellar.
I did seek Gary Gulman.
I was like,
oh my God,
somebody I know.
And uh,
I went up,
I had a good time.
And then I,
uh,
I left and I'm walking in the rain by myself,
thinking of like when I used to walk up that the sixth avenue,
I used to walk up with fucking,
you know,
fucking Bobby Kelly and all of those guys way back in the day and I'm just
fucking like,
Jesus Christ.
Where the fuck did the time go?
And then I was like,
oh my God,
now I'm getting depressed.
I can't do this.
What do I,
so I,
you know,
I called my wife,
I facetime with my kid and that was all good.
And then I got in a cab and I'm just like,
I'm not,
I'm not going to fucking,
I'm not gonna.
Uh,
you know,
what is whatever,
you have like a fucking sad thought and then you fucking just cling to it.
It's like,
I'm not fucking doing that.
I'm going to get myself in a better guide,
their mood.
So I came home,
I watched a little bit of football,
you know,
I watched the end of the fucking steal is and that she had is they get the
charges.
The steel is the shacks and more anybody in Boston remember that?
Mvp sports when they had the fucking employee do the commercial,
come on down to MVP sports.
We got all the jerseys,
we got these shacks.
The steel is the challenges and more,
um,
I watched that game and right as I go to show it up,
shut it off,
et cetera.
Fucking
fucking infuriating slash depressing fucking commercial where it's the dad with
his daughter,
you know,
and she's getting older and he has his favorite fucking song,
which is the most depressing thing ever.
It's song of regret or wish that I knew what I knew then when I was younger,
when I want to now what I know now,
whatever the fuck,
I'm like fucking mentally dyslexics.
I don't know.
I don't how that exact thing fucking goes.
And then at the end she fucking goes away.
Right.
So that's the whole song of fucking regret.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm looking back,
Jesus Christ,
I wish it fucking,
you know,
I don't need to hear that.
That's the soundtrack of my whole fucking walk home.
You know?
And I'm sitting there and that stupid commercial comes on and is,
if that commercials into depressing up,
especially on a Sunday night,
they should not be allowed to play that song on a fucking Sunday night at which
someone sit there,
they're fucking loneliness about ready to start another workweek,
a which there and who won a new dam.
Now what?
I wish I knew what I wish that I knew what I know now.
That's it.
When I was younger,
whatever the fucking song is that the end of the goddamn commercial is the
daughters all grown up.
Now the guy takes you to college,
she's fucking heartbroken.
And then she goes into her dorm room and he's got one of those fucking things.
You know,
you,
you know it.
Hey Conti,
play that song.
Me and my dad like it.
It's sitting over in the corner just listening to her.
I don't like that.
I don't like how they fucking sit there.
They're trying to make all of this shit bug in your own house,
hanging out with a robot and taking a picture with it.
No sprint commercials making us all seem like,
yeah,
hey,
this is all like a great fun fucking time.
MMM.
Or maybe I'm just lonely and I'm looking at through it.
Like you don't do it as I'm not fucking drinking either.
And I swear to God,
if I was drinking right now,
I would,
I would go to a bar by myself and uh,
that's,
and that's how you do it.
That's how you,
that's how,
that's the most healthiest way I ever figured out how to combat loneliness on
the road is to go out,
drink alone,
get shit faced,
and then come home and pass out.
And then you don't come home sober to an empty room.
But I feel like when I'm podcasting,
I have all of you here with
me.
I feel like through me,
podcasting is like giving a part of the world the hug.
What'd you guys do?
A fife really legit.
Like I fell off a bike or something and that was the result of my head injury.
And I started talking like that and I started wearing,
you know those fucking,
you know this a fragile chicks who were those sweaters that go over their hands
and they're always picking up like a cup of coffee cause they're always cold and
they have to hold it with both hands because they're fucking so weak.
If I became that person,
um,
well bill is simple,
we would listen for a few weeks and then we'd be like,
all right,
this sucks now.
And then we wouldn't,
we wouldn't listen.
Hey,
what happened over in England with the London Derby,
which I thought was like a fucking horse race.
This team that I,
I'd never even heard of,
I guess was up two to one against arsenal,
arsenal,
arsenal one nil arsenal right there.
They're fucking up on them.
And then they somehow or another,
they were up two to one.
Somali lost 42,
everybody was losing their fucking minds.
Pictures look incredible.
I wish I watched the game.
Um,
having said that,
knowing nothing about the premier league,
you know,
if he just look at both their uniforms,
you know who you're putting the money on,
you don't,
one of them looks like a professional uniform.
The other,
the people that lost that looked like a kid drew it.
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
so I just sat around all day,
uh,
fucking,
I dunno what,
watching football and shit.
I watched the,
a giants,
very entertaining game against some other team that I can't remember because I'm
fucking old.
The hell are they playing?
This is fucking unbelievable.
I watched the whole game.
I don't,
well,
I was also cleaning the fucking kitchen.
Yeah,
I know,
Susan.
It was an exciting game.
Whether they fucking plate,
I will say this,
that,
that Saquon Barkley,
that's good.
That they're telling him not to run so wide open cause he's kind of doing a
little Earl Campbell shit where it's like you don't need to take that much
punishment on every play,
especially when you're on a bad team.
Um,
that would be a shame if they finally,
you know,
became good.
And then that guy was all banged up fucking leaping over guys and shit.
Um,
it's amazing to watch,
you know.
Um,
then I watched the Patriots first the Vikings,
I was watching a,
who the fuck is that guy?
A number 19 on the vikings,
a phenomenal player.
I wish he played in our team.
But on that fourth and short,
when Bella check through the challenge lag or whatever,
and he's talking to the refs and somehow that wide receiver got involved.
You know what I mean?
To the point you literally see fucking bill Belicheck.
He's that guy.
I got to commend number 19 on the Viking Sea,
actually got an emotional response out of Bella check checks going.
She goes,
shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up.
Set it twice.
And you know what?
I don't know what was said in defense at number 19,
but you know,
just sitting at home.
Yeah.
Shut the fuck up.
You weren't even in the plate.
I can see if the running back said something.
You didn't touch the ball.
You're barely blocked on the play with the fuck are you jumping in for?
Um,
anyways,
but,
uh,
the chiefs want again,
so as much as the Patriots,
so winning the Patriots,
what they're doing this year is,
is amazing cause we lost two of our top receivers.
We lost our left tackle.
We lost a running back and we lost one of our top cornerbacks.
So this is like a fucking,
you know,
I feel like the last rebuild in the Brady Belicheck era,
hopefully we'll get under the wire again.
But,
um,
I do not feel good about playing the chiefs in Kansas City come playoff time.
But uh,
they are the fucking chiefs so until they get over the fucking hump.
But um,
I dunno,
we shall see.
We should definitely see.
And I just watched the end of the charges,
Steelers game,
the chargers,
the quietest nine and three in the NFL.
Nobody's talking about him,
you know what I mean?
Cause cause there's fucking the rams at doing so well,
right.
They like Eddie van Halen,
the rants and Alex Van Halen.
Meanwhile I was killing it right behind him and nobody seems to be noticing
except the charge offense.
Right.
Without expanding on it was only seem like other drummers,
like is it me as this guy fucking unbelievable and in his own right.
Uh,
kind of,
uh,
on Eddie's level.
Anybody else?
You maybe know,
you say a couple of fucking games behind.
I actually,
you know something,
I was getting ready to do the podcast and I saw,
um,
I went to nfl.com so I could see a couple of stats.
I wouldn't sound even dumber than usual.
And I saw there was five minutes left and the Steelers were down by seven.
I was just like,
all right,
well they got big Ben.
They're definitely coming back and you're not allowed to play defense in the
NFL.
So why don't I watch this video game here?
Scores to steal is go right,
fuck it down and bing,
Bang,
boom,
they fucking score.
And you know,
you're not allowed to pay defense in his,
uh,
you know,
there's a good minute 50 left and then the fucking charges all right down the
fucking field.
Yeah.
You know,
but it's not,
are they going to score?
It's,
are they going to get a touchdown or a field goal?
Um,
I've never seen a game and as far as like,
uh,
offsides three times on the defense,
I love that guy.
Number 25.
He's like,
fuck you,
I don't give a shit.
Keep calling a penalty.
I thought it was kind of brilliant that he just kept doing that cause he knew he
had to make a play.
And then one of the lads,
what is on that last one?
He jumped past the ball.
What if he actually blocked it?
They called them off sides again and then the next time he didn't jump off sides
and then the dude fucking misses it.
Then it makes sense.
I know he didn't explain that correctly,
but I think,
I think it makes sense.
Whatever.
I'm just a fucking lonely guy,
but a tomorrow night that'll be at Gotham and um,
got a bunch of my buddies down there,
so we'll be hanging out.
But uh,
Jesus Christ,
Jesus alone,
stone sober in New York City is,
is not,
you know,
that's not what frank was singing about when he's saying about New York.
You know,
my kind of town New York City is,
um,
anyways,
uh,
rest in peace.
41st president of the United States,
George Herbert Walker Bush.
You know,
I was amazed at the amount of people that like fucking,
I wasn't amazed,
but I wanted to see it.
People believed guy,
he's a war criminal,
right?
Somebody said that,
And then somebody else goes show a little respect.
The guys of veteran,
he was on the ground fighting with the troops are set to like that.
It's like you guys are both fucking morons.
He was a pilot.
He wasn't on the ground.
I used something for you right now.
Okay.
For all the,
you know,
and first of all in,
in a,
I don't even know what they're referring to because he was a pilot in world war
two.
So war praise they talking about and Iraq and Kuwait.
I mean,
I don't know what's going on there.
I know Saddam was our draft pick and then he went fucking crazy,
like a goddamn NFL wide receiver.
So we had to cut him right
in a military way,
I guess.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't understand how all of that shit works,
but I'll tell you something right now.
Read this book called Flags,
flags of our fathers,
Jesus Christ.
If did you,
you know,
especially if you have a pilot's license.
Um,
I just remember how fucking scared I was the first time I had to solo.
well it was really the second one I had to do.
The first one was like round trip was like an hour and it was straight up and
straight back.
I just followed this highway right up and I literally just did with my
instructor and came back.
I think it might even been a half an hour.
The second time you had to put three hours on the Hobbs meter,
which is basically the odometer of the fucking helicopter.
And um,
that is honestly the most scared I've ever been in my fucking life.
And I was flying a helicopter on a sunny day.
And just to give you an abridged version,
I hope I pick the right book at the same time.
I read this book also about Iijima but I think,
I think yeah,
flags of our fathers was,
was the book.
And um,
they were basically,
they had this mission,
George at dinner or you interviewed George Herbert Walker Bush and he was
talking about how he was like a 19 year old kid and how like you're young.
So you just had that thing that you just think you're going to,
you're not going to die.
And he said you just would always think of the other guy's going to get it.
It's not going to be me.
And just the fact that you,
you know,
any flew all these missions in it,
these guys he'd be talking to you come back and they just,
they didn't make it and you had the fucking block that out.
You know,
they sit there talking about ice in a field goal kicker.
I think about this shit.
The fucking 19 years old,
he's going through this shit,
right?
So anyways,
they have this mission,
they've got to take out some sort of of radio,
you know,
control center of the Japanese on this island and the island shaped like an old
school.
Uh,
football stayed in like a horseshoe,
like where Ohio state plays before they closed it off.
And the crazy thing,
which didn't make sense to me,
maybe it was,
that makes sense.
If it was radio,
that would be down lower,
but whatever the fuck the target they had to hit
was down low.
Right?
Like,
if you pitch basically picture,
if you're flying into the horseshoe,
right,
see flying into the open end of the stadiums and you want to go bomb the people
right behind the fucking opposing a touchdown and zone,
I should say.
And what was crazy was the Japanese anti aircraft,
um,
guns were actually,
you know,
the way the island was set up,
they were higher up than the altitude.
These guys had to fly in it.
So they were actually shooting down at them.
And anybody who's ever got into a fight at a football or baseball stadium,
you know,
if you're fighting a guy,
a row behind you,
how much did,
how much more of an advantage that person has punching down.
Now imagine this person shooting a fucking
Goddamn gun in a fucking airplane.
You know what I mean?
So they basically were flying in there.
Oh,
I skipped one part of it.
Uh Huh.
Former President Bush was talking about how you would come back from a mission,
you know,
and he said you were so fucking in shock that you got of the plane.
Like you couldn't even talk and you remembered one time getting out of his plane
after being shot at and shit and seen as other people getting shot out of the
sky and making it back.
He got out and one of the higher ups on the,
you know,
admiral,
whatever came up to him,
he said,
how you doing son?
And he said he opened his mouth and no sound came out.
Yeah.
And he said,
and then the guy goes,
oh,
I just go down to sick bay son,
you'll be finding,
said you'd go down to sick bay and they give you like two or three centuries of
fucking whiskey and you do just do a shot.
And he said,
the funny thing was that it worked.
You know,
that's just like a fucking old school shit.
Uh Oh,
you're just in a plane that people were shooting at and you're scared shitless.
I,
yeah,
go downstairs and go take a belt,
a whiskey and then tomorrow you can go do it again.
You know?
I mean,
I don't know how the fuck they slept,
you know,
all I can compare it to was just flying on a sunny day by myself.
And I just remember afterwards when I landed
and uh,
not even after I rolled down,
cause you rolled down from 100% down to like 75% just to,
you know,
you don't want to shut it off immediately because it fucks up the engine.
I just remember the greatest sound I've ever heard in my life was when I pulled
the mish mixture in the engine shut off and I was just following,
you know,
the brake to slow down the main rotor.
And I just remember thinking like,
thank God I didn't kill myself.
Right.
Yeah.
And that was just flying
in Sunny California.
And so anyways,
so he goes into F on this mission and they're taking ridiculous,
um,
anti aircraft fire because it was a really important strategic location.
And he ends up getting hit and he was flying with two other people and he was
losing control of it.
And he tells the guys in the back to bail out.
So when they bail out,
he has to hang on and stay in the fucking thing.
So they have a chance.
So they fucking bail out and he's heading down towards the water and somehow he
regains control of it.
Now the little I know about Ab,
I don't know how we did it.
I don't know if them,
the weight of them jumping out and we'd probably easily a couple of hundred
pounds,
300 pounds,
just left the back.
I don't know if that got it,
gave him enough and he was able to get over the island to the other side and
then crash in the water over there.
And,
um,
all the pilots were warned that the Japanese hated,
pilots.
They thought that they were cowards and me,
you've got to think,
you know,
aviation where it was,
this was like a new thing.
I mean,
I'm a World War II.
They had like the biplanes and shit,
but this new shit coming in and with the machine guns and bomb and people in all
that,
they were considered fucking cowards.
So,
uh,
I'm,
I begin to read the book.
The shit that they do,
the pilots is fucking nuts.
Long story short,
he crashed,
lands over there.
He sees the Japanese boat coming out to pick him up.
He's in the water.
He's 19.
He's fucking crying.
He's taken in,
you know,
sea water and shit.
And he said,
like a fucking movie.
As this thing's coming out,
like a periscope comes up and,
uh,
American sub surfaces takes out the Japanese boat and brings him onto the
fucking boat.
And he survived.
His two buddies got caught and endured like ridiculous torture before they were
killed.
And,
and,
um,
Bush ends the story saying there's,
there's not a day goes by.
I don't think about those guys.
Like,
like what I could have possibly done a fucking,
something like that.
Right?
So now had I not read that fucking book,
I would have been another idiot weighing in
on this fucking guy.
So I don't know what they're talking about when they say that shit.
All I know is that's one of the craziest fucking stories.
You know,
you guys heard me read advertising.
I'm not a big fucking reader,
but I was reading that book,
I was like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Um,
I gotta be honest.
They had,
I read that book before I got my pilot's license.
I don't know if I would have done it because I'd be thinking,
cause I'm one of those guys,
I saw jaws not right when it came back.
They brought it back.
I remember they brought it back because judge two was coming out and I think,
I want to say they brought it back and I saw it and I have never been able to,
to be comfortable with the ocean after that.
So I'm one of those bucket people,
you know,
like I'll freak myself up.
My,
my mind fucks with me in a pool and I love swimming.
But there is time,
especially out in la where they got all these fucking critters and reptiles and
shit that I'm not fucking used to.
And I always think like,
what if some fucking rattlesnake just came,
you know,
and it's freaking out because it,
it's trying to get from once,
you know,
it fell in and it's trying to get together since it's already,
dangerous as fuck.
It's not going to be in a good mood.
Yeah.
You know,
it sees me come,
you know,
fucking swimming leg,
an old man coming at it and he doesn't want to die.
Like it's going to bite me right in the top of my fucking Charlie Brown head.
Um,
anyways,
so I did you know something,
one thing I did get out of all of that because I don't follow politics and shit.
The one thing that they were complimenting him on,
the fact that when they brought down the Berlin Wall that he was smart enough
not to rub it in people's,
uh,
the Russians faces or whatever.
You know what I mean?
Cause we easily could have lost the whole thing.
Who knows?
You know,
those are the two big boys going at it.
Two heavyweights.
Um,
especially now with the Internet and it's all like,
hey,
fuck it.
Well,
maybe next time I literally watched,
I,
I fucking pulled up a video,
right?
I was trying to poach salmon tonight.
Right?
I don't mean steal it.
Um,
and uh,
how to poach salmon and the name of the video is you're doing it all wrong.
And it's just like,
why?
It's like,
why the fuck would you come at it that way?
You know,
just be like,
hey,
this is how I make salmon.
Some people do it this way.
I feel like if you do it this way,
that you know,
this happens.
Okay.
It's just like everything has to be like,
hey,
maybe next time,
don't put the put,
put the fucking deal on until you fucking whatever.
It's like Jesus is even hostility and fucking cooking videos.
Like,
I remember this freckled can show me how to make a pie crust.
One time I just realized what a hypocrite I was being.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
guess what,
guess who wears a new podcast?
Everybody.
The great Conan O'brien.
MMM.
He has a new podcast and he was nice enough to ask me to be a guest on it and
you can listen to it today.
I'm going to be on it.
And you're probably like,
well,
Jesus Christ,
Bill,
where the hell is it?
Um,
I don't have the information in front of me.
Wait a minute.
Four.
Hang on.
It's now you have to go find it.
Hold on a second.
God dammit.
Bill,
how many fucking times Conan O'brien,
I mean,
you could do this too,
right?
Oh,
Brian
podcast,
um,
Kona needs a friend podcast on earwolf.com Jesus Christ.
I'm promoting a different podcast network.
Um,
anyways,
I'll be on that.
I had a great time on his podcast and uh,
obviously,
you know,
he's,
he's one of the,
one of my most favorite people in this business.
MMM.
I've always said one of my favorite things ever is somebody who's super smart
and this is silly and that's why I've always loved him and Andy,
cause they're both obviously really smart people and they're silly as hell.
And I had a great time on his podcast.
Please listen to it.
It's actually really cool because I learned more about Conan than I ever knew.
Just shooting the shit with them in that hour.
So if you're into Conan O'brien,
like you should be,
check it out.
There we go.
Um,
also it's the first of the month,
the beginning of the month.
So,
uh,
my patrion page,
patrion.com/bar,
uh,
we got a bunch of a new buying the scenes stuff that we put up there.
We got a bill birth three arenas and his backstage from all the arena shows I
did in 2018,
um,
me getting ready to go on stage,
me coming off stage,
uh,
me jamming with Conan O'brien at the forum,
Dean Del Rey,
uh,
Michael,
Devin and a bunch of other people.
Um,
it's what I do before I do those shows.
Always get together with some friends,
play some music in the empty arena so I'm not too freaked out when I go out
there later.
Two new episodes of uninformed with the teen idols.
Sensation from the and Anthony Program is to Joe to Rosa.
Um,
and we also have,
um,
I did a live podcast at stand up live in Phoenix,
Arizona.
We have the whole show up there.
So,
uh,
there you go.
You get all of that for five bucks and I swear to God at some point I'm just
going to start also making random videos for that.
I've just been,
um,
I just been really busy.
But anyways,
check it out if you would like.
All right.
Uh,
okay,
now I want to,
I done yet 25 minutes.
I think it's time to read a little bit of advertising year.
Um,
did I even upload the advertising onto here?
I probably didn't.
Oh,
Bill.
I mean how,
how,
how long,
how long do you have to do a podcast before you're a little bit more of a pro
and you just a little bit more prepared.
Alright,
here we go.
Oh my God.
Cody needs a friend that just made me depressed and then I wish that a new word.
And then when we younger,
that's,
that's depressing me.
And by my,
I got to get out of this,
you know,
oh my God,
should I go fat person on this?
Should I go buy a pint of ice cream?
Um,
frame bridge everybody.
If you're a listener of this show,
you heard me talk about frame bridge,
frame bridge makes it ridiculously easy and affordable to custom frame your
favorite things from art prints and posters to the photos on your phone.
Now with the holidays fast approaching frame bridge is the easiest way to send
truly one of a kind gifts to everyone on your list.
Here's how it works.
Just go to [inaudible] Dot Com and upload your video or they'll send you a
package to safely mail in your physical pieces.
Preview your item online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get free recommendations from their child to desire.
Sorry,
the expert team at frame bridge.
We'll custom frame your item and delivery your finished piece straight to you or
whenever you need it.
They completely handmade.
Personalized from frame.
Bridge starts at $39 is delivered in days in all shipping is free.
Plus,
my listeners will get 15% off their first
order@framebridge.com when they use my code burr.
I've used these guys.
They're great.
Um,
I've got a bunch of great pictures from when I was in France with my lovely wife
and my beautiful data.
Um,
you know,
in some day me and my daughter will have a song and it won't be something that
fucking depressing.
You know,
it's going to be like Ben n
bad,
bad.
Here I am.
Let's give me some sort of 80s
rob me like uh,
um,
can anybody tell me what he says there?
Um,
but don't wait.
I'm going to actually look that up and singing in falsetto for you after this
read.
But don't wait.
Make sure to place your order on Monday,
December 17th for guaranteed delivery by December 24th.
Fuck.
I have to do this.
Um,
cause there's a picture I want to get for somebody.
Give your personal experience using frame bridge.com.
I already did.
It's fucking awesome with just a few taps on your phone frame bridge.
Let you create,
lets you create a one of a kind gift that will win Christmas and make someone
happy for years to come.
Go to frame bridge.com and use Promo Code [inaudible].
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order,
plus free delivery in time for Christmas.
If you order by Monday,
December 17th,
just go to [inaudible] dot com Promo code per frame frame,
bridge.com Promo Code Burn.
You know as much as I listened to this scorpions because they all had those
foreign fucking names too foreign to my ear.
I can't fucking,
I know he's was like Michael Schreiner.
The fuck was the lead singer's name.
Lead singer
of a,
I say poison.
I meet poison of a fucking,
uh,
the scorpions.
We all know Bret Michaels.
I mean,
that's a nice fucking straight ahead American name there.
Klaus mine.
All right,
here we go.
Klaus.
He had to become a rock singer.
How the fuck he get married?
Married.
How do you get fucking laid within fucking name?
I've been married so long.
I fucking went to that.
All right.
Wait a second.
Rock.
You like a hurricane?
Lyrics.
All right.
Yeah,
I mean it's an emotion in the sun comes out.
Oh,
the other reverse snack
late at night.
Well shaking and pretty loud.
My cat is purring and scratches my skin.
So what is wrong with,
uh,
no,
the bitches,
Hungary.
She needs to tell.
So give her inches and feet are well.
Oh Jesus.
More,
more days to come.
New places to go.
I've got to leave.
It's time for a show.
Here I am.
Rock.
You like a hurricane.
Here I am.
Rock.
Like a Harvard.
They don't even know.
Oh,
he says,
are you ready baby?
He says more than that.
He ran him.
No,
no,
no.
Rocky black.
A.
Okay.
He's going to say fucking in there.
You said something else.
All right,
let's get back to the read.
Sorry.
All right.
No,
that's not where they are.
They were over here a little Billy clicking here.
Alright.
Tipsy elves.
Oh Jesus.
Stay away before you get me to food.
Uh,
everyone,
everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater this time of year.
Do you want the bragging rights for the most talked about sweater with the
holiday parties than wait until you see it sounds like nobody's getting laid at
this party.
Then wait until you see tipsy elves.
Hilariously re-imagined,
irreverent,
new designs,
stylish Christmas,
whatever averages the women's showing up dress like Santa whores and you still
in the corner like dumb fucker.
Stylish Christmas suits for the classiest of holiday.
Gentlemen,
that's a day.
That's a time gone by.
Um,
interactive sweaters,
beer pong,
corn hole,
drinking game darts.
So uncle Bob,
can we live?
Is College glory days at family dinners.
They should switch that to uncle bill.
Even though I didn't really go to college.
I did,
but I commuted.
You know what I mean?
That's like you took a tour of college,
you know,
and then you went home every day.
You sure you want to go there?
I think I am,
but I'm not sure.
And even hilarious theme teas and awesome,
cozy onesies.
You know,
I thought onesies for adults where we're really fucking weird.
But I'm starting to warm up to the idea of,
no pun intended for women holiday dresses.
So you can get down with your bad self.
Oh Jesus,
I catching leggings.
See can strike a festive yoga pose.
There they are,
this and his little horse or lounge around with a cup of spiked eggnog and tease
that sleigh in cute tease,
that sleigh and cute comfy ones.
These they even sell bright crazy ski suits for when you're shredding some Nar
this holiday season.
I don't understand what that is.
Uh,
you can't,
you won't find more hilariously awesome designs anywhere else.
So be sure to order from tipsy elves in time for your ugly Christmas sweaters.
Now make sure you get consent from these tipsy elves before you ordered mass
than them make sweaters.
All right before they're triggered.
And Right now my listeners get 20% off tips.
He yells.com when you use my code burr at checkout,
that's 20% off anything you order on the site,
go to tipsy elves.com and enter my code Burr at checkout to get 20% off.
Sitewide discount a low goose bag.
My bookie,
everybody I eat doing,
I ain't doing.
I live on the hill.
A sharer watching football is fun,
but it's more entertaining.
When you got a little action on the game over the a guys,
you've heard,
guys,
you've heard me talking about this for weeks and some of you are still on the
sidelines and you better get off cause it's fucking December.
Uh,
whether you're an expert or a rookie,
you should be betting at my booking.
If through the kind of guy that likes to bet a little and when a lot like
playing the numbers on roulette,
you can create a big par laid pick three teams to win.
If you hit all three,
you could turn a hundred bucks into 600.
You can buy a lot of ugly sweaters for that.
Uh,
there's so much to bet on college basketball and football,
NBA,
Nhl,
custom props,
even east sports,
you name it.
Um,
I recommend these guys because I really trust them according to the copy.
My book,
he's been in business for years,
they've got great online reviews in their mobile site is easy to use.
Sign up this week and my book,
you will give you a 50% deposit bonus to jump Satch back row.
It's a great way to bank even more money when you win.
How do you get hiccups in the middle of fucking reading?
Um,
also make sure to follow at bet my bookie on Twitter.
They personally respond to every mention in DM.
Uh,
not to mention the even give away more than not $10,000 in free money to their
followers this football season.
You'll be the first to know as soon as the new odds and props are posted.
Don't miss out on one of the best weeks to bet on sports this year.
Log onto my bookie right now and use the Promo Code Burt,
uh,
to get 50 to get a 50%.
Want to get a 50% deposit bonus.
That's Promo Code Burr.
You play,
you win,
you get paid.
Jesus Christ.
I hope you do better gamble.
And then I did read in that last bucket sentence.
All right,
last one.
Movement watches MVMT founded on the behalf.
That style shouldn't break the bank.
They've sold nearly 2 million watches worldwide by bringing quality design at
fair prices.
Movement watches are all about looking good while keeping it simple.
They don't tell you how many steps you've taken or blow your wrist up with text
messages,
parentheses you up.
Oh,
they're taking a shot of smart fucking watchers.
They love it.
Uh,
they're not overly intrusive on life with notifications,
text messages,
emails,
et Cetera.
They tell time like true classic time pieces should and look good doing it.
Movement watches start at just $95.
You're looking at $400 for the same quality from a traditional band brand idea.
Talk about all the things you can buy with that saved money,
I could buy some hiccup medication.
Um,
if you need to help,
if you need help bringing the perfect gift,
giving the perfect gift this season,
but don't know where to start.
The guys over at MVMT got your back.
They did all the had work this holiday season.
She wouldn't have to buy curating their favorite styles into awesome gift boxes
and packages.
Get 25% off today during MVM teas.
Black Friday slash cyber Monday sale with free shipping and free returns by
going to mvmt.com/burr movement watches launches new styles on their site all
the time.
Check out their latest set.
mvmt.com uh,
go to MV
empty.com/bar.
Alright.
Mercifully they'd fucking reads are.
Imagine I'll get a little blow back for that fucking tipsy elves wants.
So please buy some of those ugly sweaters.
Okay.
For Fuck Sakes.
Whatever.
I'm lonely.
You know,
what do you,
what are you going to do sometimes?
You know,
the copy comes out a different way.
I'll tell you right now,
I couldn't,
I can't believe the amount of fucking people you know,
that walk around in New York with their nose in their phone,
especially when you're waiting for a subway.
Jesus Christ's like back in the day,
you know,
it's being pushed.
People push people in front of those fucking trains.
New Yorkers.
Can you please get,
get,
you know,
you got,
what do they have that as situational awareness?
Good Lord.
They just fucking trains coming in and they're leaning against the post just
staring at their fucking phone.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
LH chargers quite as 93.
I already talked about that.
What else?
Seth Meyers,
I'm doing that on Tuesday.
I'm doing the gym and Sam Show,
um,
today,
Monday when you're hearing this and uh,
yeah,
going to buy a shirt for that too.
It was just the weirdest thing.
You can wear the same fucking pants every,
every time you ever do fucking,
um,
a talk show,
but you have to always have to have a new shirt,
you know?
That's why George,
another way,
George Carlin was a fucking genius cause he always wore the black and black,
you know,
the black sweater with the black.
But that was just his fucking look,
this is what I'm wearing.
You don't have to think,
you know,
going Einstein with it.
So then he just shows up and it's just like,
oh,
it's people just getting the benefit of the doubt.
It's probably a new books where you was fucked up.
Like my,
the time on my laptop is a la times.
I'm thinking,
why am I this tired at nine 16?
And then I just looked at the fucking TV and it's 12,
17.
Oh Jesus,
I gotta be up early tomorrow.
Um,
all right,
let's read some of these questions here for this week.
Uh,
fantastic cars and uh,
oh second shows will be added this week to the European tour.
I'm not sure what day yet.
Just check on Twitter and bill bird.com for dates.
Uh,
I can't believe you know,
all these places I'd never been to before.
All these people showing up.
Um,
it's one of the reasons why I'm not drinking right now is because I want to be
in great shape when I get over there and give you guys your money worth.
All right.
I'm not flying halfway across the fucking globe to have a mediocre set,
um,
halfway across the country.
Yeah,
I'll drink,
you know,
I'll be,
I'll be a little under the weather.
All right.
But,
you know,
I feel like when I go overseas,
I am an ambassador for Shit and Dick Jokes from my country,
uh,
fantastic cars in f is for family.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
getting back to that,
that criticism of George Herbert Walker Bush and stuff,
if you see like,
um,
just read that book.
And I think that sometimes,
you know,
people tend to,
just see the evil on one side where there's just like,
uh,
if you're overly patriotic,
you only see your enemies evil.
And if you're overly fucking like liberal,
you only see your own country's evil.
And it's,
it's,
you know,
I think the theme of this is depressing because I read that book and it's just
like,
I just cannot fucking believe human beings could do that to other human beings.
And I know we're guilty of it.
I know everybody else is guilty of it.
It's just like,
it's,
it always goes back to that fucking thing I saw on the discovery channel that
time,
that monkey could have just killed the other monkey.
And it didn't,
it was a smaller monkey.
And this one,
they first realizing that chimpanzees,
eight,
eight other monkeys and in a just was fucking keeping the other monkey alive
just,
and it was getting off on the things pain.
And I,
I've ever since that,
every fucking time I see something on fucking TV about human beings doing
something horrible to other human beings.
For some reason that plays in my head and I'm like,
we're just fucking hairless monkeys.
Um,
which is something Rogan might've said or something.
I Dunno,
I'm fucking tired.
Um,
anyways,
not that clip.
He might've used that reference,
but anyways,
uh,
fantastic cars and F is for family.
Hi Bill.
I've just attended my 50th car show this year.
Wow.
That's more than one a week.
Uh,
I don't think I've ever been to a car show.
I've gone,
I used to go to the car shows,
you know,
showing the latest,
the brand new cars.
You know,
I used to go to that car show,
but I would like to go to the,
uh,
mmm,
I'd like to go to a vintage one.
Anyways,
I've just attended my 50th car show this year,
so I'm starting to get pretty good at identifying makes and models of cars from
all around the world.
Uh,
I post all my photos on my public Facebook page,
classic and modern show cars.
A you,
I gotta check that out.
Uh,
I'm enjoying the third season of F is for family.
Thank you very much.
And I am struck by what,
by the way,
that all of the cars have been lovingly drawn in such pain staking Lee detail
that it's possible for a car fanatic like me to identify every single car in
this show.
My question is,
who's artistic vision was it to make such a conscious effort to depict all of
the cars?
So realistically,
uh,
not just the ones in the center of the action,
but all of the cars in the background as well.
I know that you're a car guy,
so I wonder if you had any influence of the aspect of the,
of the production.
Thanks and love to you and Nia and the Kiddo.
Um,
yeah,
that was an important thing with everybody.
Certainly people who were into cars on the show,
because back then also,
you know,
mmm,
cars really looked unique back then and they had a lot more personality to them
just because
I guess I learned when I did Seinfeld's comedians in cars and was basically with
all the safety regulations,
which is great cause less people die unless you're an environmentalist and then
that's not a good thing.
But you know,
less people fucking die.
But because of the parameters of the safety regulations,
the,
the area where the artists could create became a lot smaller.
So stuff started looking more similar.
But back then,
especially if you watch me on TV,
like one of the big things back in the day was,
um,
you know,
the star of the show if he,
if he was a bad ass or whatever,
like it was really like,
it was a big thing.
What fucking car we drove,
what Car Jack Lord drove on a Hawaii five o um,
you know what,
what like Jim Rockford,
um,
on the Rockford files,
he drove a Firebird.
It was like the top of the line Firebird,
but he didn't have a trans am.
And I always heard that James Garner has said this,
this guy,
Jim Rockford wouldn't,
wouldn't drive a trans am.
He wouldn't have the money.
He'd had the money to get the really good one,
but not the great one.
And,
um,
and I used to always watch the Rockford files when I was a kid and I didn't
realize how much that guy was struggling in his personal life.
Literally living in a trailer on the fucking beach,
never married.
Um,
and knowing that now and being old and all of that stuff,
and is,
uh,
it's like,
it's the perfect car.
So,
um,
the reason why in all the cars are loosely based on,
you know,
cars that were around back then.
Um,
one of my dream cars that I always wanted was a,
uh,
um,
when I got older and I really got into cars,
was a 65 Ford galaxy.
And I always loved the Ford,
the Wimbledon white.
And if you could get that with that Ford Blue Interior.
And I mean,
I,
that's just,
that's just a fucking man's car,
you know,
I'm not into the muscle cars.
I liked the muscle cars.
I respect him.
I liked him when I was a kid and I always feel like,
you know,
when you're a kid,
you like the frosting better than the cake.
And when you get older you're more into the cake and the frosting.
Uh,
or maybe just so many.
I watched enough of those Meekum and it's just like one Shelby,
one Hemi after another.
I liked those fucking cars.
But,
um,
at this point if I was going to go like a sports cars and shit,
I just like ran.
I really like random weird shit.
And I always,
you know,
I think I watched every fucking episode online before Jay Leno had his show of
that Jay's garage.
And one of my favorite cars that he had was that,
I think it was a Datsun five 10.
And it's a,
it's a four door,
like
basically,
uh,
you know,
sports car that Datsun put out.
It's really boxy.
The lines of the car are fucking so cool.
And I remember,
you know,
one,
one of my friends when I was a kid had an 81 Toyota Tercel and it was to this
day,
it was the smoothest shifting car.
Um,
you mean it wasn't fast?
It was goofy is front wheel drive and it's sat up really high.
It was like 81 or something like that ugly car.
But I just remember shifting it.
It was a four speed and just was like,
when it went from one gear to another,
it was like butter.
And it was this awful time where,
uh,
American cars had embraced what they did with the light bulb from day one with
rather than,
you know,
they had the technology to make it last for a long time and they decided to not
make it,
you know,
design obsolescence,
whatever they call it.
We were doing that with cars and I swear to God,
American cars would shit the bed or on 60,000 miles,
it was fucking brutal.
And the Japanese cars were,
we're trying to establish themselves,
you know,
in America,
and so they,
they went the other route and we're really focusing on quality and,
uh,
that fucking,
I'll never forget that.
So I was thinking,
I,
I would love to drive one of those one of these days.
Like,
I just think,
you know,
it's f I also like a lot of small cars.
Um,
you know,
I like those bigger cars,
but I always felt like if you drove like a big American car,
like you had to be a big guy,
you know,
kind of a guy's guy going into a bar and everybody kind of clears a path or
fucking respect you.
You know,
I just,
I just didn't feel like,
you know,
it barely five,
10,
like I was one of those guys.
So I always liked the A,
we started look better in a smaller car.
Uh,
but I've also always been like a truck guy and all that type of stuff.
So adding said that,
um,
I'm one of those weird guys where I'm a Ford Guy,
but I also love Chevy's.
And,
um,
I don't mean,
I don't know how you can be a truck guy,
not like an F-150 f two 50 and then look at a Silverado and not like that or a
dodge ram,
especially back in the day.
Cause I think all the trucks,
the internationals and then the random dodge once that you see are those are
always cool because you don't see those a lot.
So anyways,
each character,
you know,
the car that Vic drives,
um,
the car that pogo drives that he's,
you know,
he's like a Cadi guy.
You know,
Frank's afford guide.
Vic's got the,
you know,
he's got the core event,
we made a gold,
you know,
like the color of Vic's hair and just,
cause fic is basically,
as far as it's kind of frank looks at Vic,
like that's how my life could have been if I,
if I didn't get married,
you know,
he knocked up,
his wife is basically what happened.
He was going to marry yourself,
but he ended up having to get married sooner than he wanted to.
So we had to put some dreams on hold.
So when he looks across,
you know,
write out his bay window,
he just sees this guy live in this life.
You know,
and the funny thing is is frank wouldn't have lived that life because frank
wasn't evict type of guy.
He wasn't a lady killer.
He was a fucking relationship guy.
And I think a lot of relationship guys,
they have fantasy is that they could have been a lady killer rather than just
accepting their role.
You know what I mean?
Like you're on a team and you,
you know,
accepting your fucking roll.
Instead you want more minutes instead of coming off the bench where if you come
off the bench,
the team wins.
But if you don't eat,
want more w who's a coach Riley the disease and more so anyways,
I'm fucking guys,
I'm half asleep or something.
Fucking babbling.
Um,
yeah.
When the kids,
MMM,
it says there's a 65 and Paula that Bolo and Lex have.
And I always loved the round headlights on that thing and I always loved,
I mean the impalas,
late sixties impalas,
mid to late sixties and piles.
I love those things.
I know a lot of people,
like especially the west coast guys,
the rappers and stuff,
they like the early sixties ones,
which I really like.
Um,
I like the one,
what is it,
the 61,
the one that lily had a,
a plane,
a jet on the side of it.
That's the one that I like.
Um,
and what are the ones,
I dunno.
So by basically,
yeah,
we,
we try to make sure if there's a,
if there's a like a,
um,
and the reason why,
this is a great question cause I haven't really thought about this.
The reason why sue frank Frank's wife drives the,
the Ford Country Squire,
you know,
with the wood down the side is uh,
because my best friend when I was a kid across the street,
mmm.
His mom who was coolest,
how she had one.
And I was just thinking about the early seventies and that type of stuff where
my life was at.
There's a lot of real subtle stuff in there.
There's a guide from last season,
last name Linehan,
that was the last name.
It's funny in the show,
the guy was a jerk.
But on my paper route that it was a great house.
Like they were really cool people and they always tip me well and we just needed
a name.
And that was the first thing that I thought of.
So,
uh,
yeah,
the A,
by the way,
if you guys keep watching the show,
whatever questions you ask,
I'm not going to give away anything,
you know,
as far as story or anything like that,
but just as far as like some of the details.
But we really,
when we went to make the show,
um,
I never thought the 70s were sort of accurately portrayed after the 70s who were
over.
MMM.
It always seem to be more of the way they did it on that seventies show where it
was like,
you know,
making fun of the crazy clothes and the lava lamps and um,
which definitely was going on that.
But like if you look at like,
uh,
like I love that movie dazed and confused,
right.
But the high school parking lot is fucking ridiculous.
Those are high school kids and they were driving cars from the 70s,
if I remember correctly.
And the reality is,
is most people,
like the average person,
I think with their car be three,
four years old.
And when,
and when I was younger,
a lot of them were either a lot older because people just,
I dunno,
they did,
they didn't,
weren't living the lifestyle people live now or like something's considered old
three years in,
you know,
with the fucking two year lease every two years I got a new fucking car,
you know.
So like in the early seventies there was a ton of cars left over from the 60s.
I mean they were only like,
you know,
five to,
uh,
whatever,
15 years old,
14 years old,
he saw a bunch of those and then like,
you know,
cars from the 50s,
those were considered really old because also the style look really different.
So occasionally,
you know,
we tried to throw a car in for the 1950s,
like if you looked at Sanford and son,
it's a truck they had,
which I believe was in 1950 or 51 Ford f 100 with the radiator was out front.
I'm just totally exposed.
And,
um,
there was no grill or anything on it and that was to show that they didn't have
any money,
that they were driving that thing.
And now it was funny about that.
Now is if you saw that coming down the street,
you'd be like,
aw,
fuck all original Patina and,
and all of that shit.
Um,
but back then it was just like,
no,
they drove there in a junkyard.
These guys aren't making a lot of money.
Um,
all right.
That's one of the longest answers I ever gave,
but I love my show and I love cars,
right?
A company raffle prize,
dear Billy private pants.
Hey,
what that means.
Um,
anyways,
the company I work at recently had an outing where everyone from the company was
invited.
At the outing there was a raffle that was set up where you could win a prize and
that's in quotes.
The prize was a small statue of yourself that you could get for free from a
different company that was hired for this purpose.
I have to read that sentence again.
The prize was a small statue of yourself
that you could get for free from a different company that was hired for this
purpose.
Okay?
They do this by scanning your entire body.
All my God sending that data to their servers.
Three,
three,
three d printing your body as a three inch tall statue and they send the statute
to your house.
Yeah,
dude,
I swear to God,
I swear to fucking God.
If you ever bugged one of those Bilderberg meetings,
they are planning a worldwide thinning of the fucking heard,
replacing you with a fucking robot.
Anyways,
so in total this company would receive the following information about you,
your full name,
your email address,
your phone number,
the company you work at,
your home address,
and a three d scan of your entire body.
It's nice to know there's another thinking human being out there.
They were hundreds of people lined up for this prize.
As I was standing there looking at people in that line,
they were all indistinguishable from cattle.
Exactly.
What do you think about it?
You know what actually you don't even think about.
He said,
what do you,
what do you or he or she says,
what do you think?
Would you stand in on an hour long line for the chance to give away your soul?
Thanks for all your,
the laughs.
I hope this message gets to you,
dude.
And He sends sincerely,
none of your business,
sincerely not your business.
Exactly.
You know what?
What if,
what if that's the test.
One of the fact that you were smart enough not to get in that line
was the test.
We'll wait a minute.
Then the tests would be,
well,
this guy's a problem.
He's not going to do what we say.
So maybe if you don't get in the line,
you get whacked.
I don't know.
There's so many ways to look at it.
I have no idea.
But I just want to thank you on this lonely,
depressing night that I'm having here that you gave me hope that somebody else
views stuff like that the way I do.
Um,
anyways,
female warriors and the worst people.
When you bring that up.
The worst point people,
I mean,
he'd done that and they're gonna fucking yet in anyway.
Those people just fucking tuck them balls by and the legs.
All right.
Female Warriors.
Mr. Barr,
I am a huge fan of your comedy and a bigger fan of F is for family.
The third season they had me rolling on the floor laughing so hard.
My sides were hurting.
I feel like you're setting up.
Having said that,
I think you're a con anyways,
which is a compliment to your genius and comedy.
I am graduating December with my second degree in English literature.
The first being in history,
you know.
Oh,
look at you.
Yes,
Maddie.
I bet you know all the words there.
I'm writing you.
I'm writing to you not to show bias at all.
I am just hoping to Pique your interest in history a bit.
Oh boy.
To get to the point.
Throughout history,
females have indeed participated in wars dating back to the Stone Age.
Some examples include Boudicca a queen who led a barbarian rev rebellion in
Britain the first century Aidy after she and her daughters were tortured and had
their lands ceased by Roman forces.
That sounds like a great movie though.
She failed.
She in the end,
let over 50,000 barbarians on a rampage against Rome and killed possibly 2
million citizens.
Sources vary,
but you get the picture.
Joan of arc needs no explanation.
Yeah,
it does.
I thought she was in a whale's mouth,
wasn't she?
Another example I think you would find interesting is a woman from the u s women
from the USSR during World War Two,
a woman named lid lie diem.
Lydia,
Mo
follow
Chenko Pavlot Chenko Russians have cool.
Last name.
Pavlik Chenko onto the Blue Line.
Pablet Chenko shoots he go eyes.
Uh,
she got shot in the jaw and yet still killed the enemy sniper and walked away
like it was nothing.
I just find it interesting that women can be quite deadly when the time calls
for it.
I don't find that interesting.
I fucking,
I watched the first 48.
What's your take on women who took combative roles in history?
Just hoping for funny yet in lightening responses and knowing you,
you never fail.
Hope to see more of your work and looking forward to season four.
Um,
I don't,
I,
I dunno dude,
I am,
I am fascinated and have nothing but respect for anyone that fights in a fucking
war.
But it,
it,
yeah,
it blows my fucking mind
that you can get in trouble now for a joke.
But war is still legal.
It does.
The war is still like an option to solve a difference of opinion between two
nations.
That it's like,
all right,
basically we're going to kill more of your people than you can kill a vars and
then that means we're going to be right.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
having said that,
all those stories that you said were amazing.
You know,
I love these.
I love that you thought I was smart enough to know what Joan of arc did.
I have no fucking idea.
She,
the sister,
that guy who betrayed Jesus,
didn't she end up in a whale whale's mouth or something?
And you know,
isn't it like the Female Pinocchio Story or something?
Joan of arc.
All right.
Joan of arc nickname,
the maid of Orleans.
Oh,
a saints fan,
uh,
is consider it a heroine of France
for her role during the [inaudible] phase of the Hundred Years War was canonized
as a Roman Catholic saint.
Oh,
they shot her ashes into the year she was born to,
I don't give a fuck.
What did she do?
All right.
On May 23rd,
she was cute.
Oh,
fucking Christ.
Oh my God.
This is just,
you don't wanna.
You know why I don't know anything about this cause I,
I hate this part of history.
I can never read the fucking names.
Charles the seventh,
we cannot recover Francis domination.
A hundred years of the unknown.
King Charles the seventh sense.
Joan of Arc sent Joan to the seas of orderliness,
part of all released mission.
She gained prominence after the seas was lifted.
Only nine days later,
several additional swift victories led to Charles' sevens coronation at realms
like,
what does that even mean?
And I have to look up coronation this long awaited event boosted French fries.
She did something in a war.
Who is the one that ended up on the,
didn't she get like crucified or something?
Captured.
Trial.
Cross dressing.
Charge execution.
Jesus Christ.
Why did that just make me think of Bruce Jenner,
a truce with England trial.
There's a trial for heresy.
What is heresy saying?
Bad Shit about the king.
Oh,
saying bad shit about Christianity.
It always goes back to religion.
You know,
it's weird how religion affects people.
Some people make some stop drinking other people.
It makes them go to an island and get shot with arrows.
It's,
it's very dangerous.
You know,
it's like some people can handle alcohol,
other people can.
Um,
all right,
I'll have to,
I'll have to read up on her.
Um,
is there a movie about us to want to read?
what is my take on it?
Uh,
what do they say?
Hell hath no fury like a woman scorned.
Um,
I would hate to see women acting like men,
um,
as far as,
you know,
going to war and all that shit and then having them having to deal with the
nightmares and the fucking suicidal thoughts.
And all of that shit.
It's just really,
uh,
this is weird time right now where it's like the support of the troops and all
that is to the point that you can't really like talk about how bad it is that
these kids have to go over and do shit like that and then somehow emotionally
try to get fucking through it.
And then the striking lack of,
uh,
support they get when they come back.
I Dunno.
All of that shits to put a lot of depressing shit here.
All right.
Others will,
Oh boy,
you just,
somebody pulled me out of the fucking a lagoon here.
Hey Billy bulldog
after trouble convincing my 47 year old father to sort out his will in the event
that he passes away for some unforeseen circumstances.
Well,
I gotta be honest with you.
If I was only 47 years old and my kid was going like,
Hey dad,
you finish that will yet I think I'd start sleeping with one eye open.
Um,
if such a tragedy were to occur,
now his assets would automatically go to my so called stepmother.
Oh,
now I see you motivation who he has only been with for a few years.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
You can't do that.
As I'm sure you would agree.
It would be unwise to give this much trust to a woman who was nothing stopping
her from simply taking my father's assets for herself and leaving me cause only
child empty handed.
Uh,
is there any piece of advice you could give my father or I could I to help
persuade them to wisen up and get this?
We'll sort it out.
Uh,
as always,
many thanks for the great work you put in and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I gotta tell you that's an uphill battle on two levels.
One,
you're,
you're talking to a guy asking him to deal with his own mortality,
which men do not handle well,
and then also,
you know,
that's his chick.
You know,
you know,
it is when someone's with somebody
that's hard for them to fucking see what you're talking about.
So,
MMM,
Jesus Christ,
I'm fucking tired and fucking bombing on these questions.
I Dunno.
I would start playing catch with your dad.
All right.
Maybe while you can slip into points you want to make while doing a fun activity
like that and just be like that,
you know,
I know you love her.
I'm not saying leave everything to me.
You know what,
how about this?
How about fuck all of that and you make your own money.
You know what I mean?
I know what you're saying.
Cause it'd be difficult to see some fucking broad only banged your dad for two
years.
Get your house.
You know,
you haven't said she's an asshole though.
But um,
uh,
the way it goes is,
is to make your own way in life.
That's the way to do it.
Um,
just don't take over the family business unless you fucking want to win.
Who gives a shit,
dude?
Look,
if your dad's only 47 years old,
even if he had you at like fucking 25,
you're only 22 years old.
So I mean,
I don't think you've got to be eyeball in the fucking wheel at this point,
but I understand what you're saying.
Um,
that's a weird one to bring up though.
Yeah,
that would definitely weird me up.
But if you're going to do it,
that's what I would do.
I would go fishing with them.
I played catch with them.
I would do something where we were doing a different activity.
Um,
but the bottom line is that,
that,
you know,
trying to get it up fucking man to go out and get a will done is about as easy
as trying to get a drunk to get sober.
It's like they have to want to go fucking do it.
Yeah.
Um,
so
I would use this as motivation few to not to get yourself into position that you
don't give a shit,
uh,
that your dad passes.
Other than the fact that you sad that he's gone.
Forget about,
you know,
you getting his fucking bowling bag in the house and shit.
Um,
alright.
Boss's wife wants,
wants to fuck me.
Yeah.
Do I really have to read this dude?
You know what to do.
No,
don't do it.
All right.
Hey,
Billy badass.
I'm a big fan of the podcast.
Here's my question.
I work in a grocery store in Brooklyn Heights.
Oh God,
I'm sorry.
I'm so tired.
I normally don't say where you're at.
I'm 21 years old and in college I worked at the corner store for some extra
cash.
My boss is a great guy and he really likes me.
Obviously I can't work for him every day since I'm,
I've got college and stuff,
but he always wants me to be the supervisor of the other guys.
We've been working there much longer than me and work longer hours.
Here's the issue.
My wife's,
my boss,
his wife is a fine looking lady and about 35 I'd say she's a nine and a half.
Even if she got 14 on me is
really into me.
At first I thought she was just being friendly,
but she's become a lot less subtle about it.
Yeah.
But Hey chicks in their thirties,
they know what they want.
Uh,
they don't beat around the bush.
Then,
uh,
on days when she knows I'll be working,
she wears many,
many skirts and sometimes a crop top.
She stared at my crotch all the time and laughs at my jokes.
I'm not a funny guy.
Jesus Christ.
She invited me up to their house last week when the boss was out of town.
I made some excuse.
I wouldn't have to go up there,
but I don't know what to do here.
You know it's funny.
This is,
this is a,
this is a classic example of sexual harassment that will never be fucking
reported because now she's abusing her position of power where it's like now if
you don't Banger,
then she'll fucking maybe say something bad and you two are her husband.
Maybe even say that you grabbed her ass.
God knows what the fuck she's gonna do a,
she's smoking hot,
but she's a married woman.
Exactly.
Not only that,
but my boss is a great guy who's been really great to meet.
I don't know what my options are here.
Here are,
you know exactly what your options are by tell my boss about my wife,
about his wife is probably going to fire me and I really need this job.
Don't fucking do that.
On the other hand,
if I don't tell them,
I'm probably going to end up giving it,
giving into her.
I only have so much control.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
This is what you need.
Well,
she's never said I want to fuck you.
So,
um,
oh God.
Here's the thing,
just don't fuck her.
That's it.
Rub One out before you go to war.
Give fucking 21.
Rub it out twice and just fucking go to work.
Put your head down.
And just that,
I don't know.
That's it.
And well,
don't,
don't put it too far down corporate fucking skirt.
Um,
I would just high in buyer,
that's it.
She'll quit after I,
I imagine she will quit after awhile.
Although if she's a nine and a half,
okay,
that gets dangerous because you know,
hot women age as well as former athletes do where it's just one day that the
Belle of the ball and then all of a sudden the cheering stops and nobody gives a
shit anymore.
And then they kind of have to,
you know,
develop a fucking personality.
So like you,
by you not giving into her might trigger some fucked up shit with her.
But here's the thing,
dude,
I under no circumstances can you fucking bang this woman.
You can't do it.
All right.
So what I would do is I would continue to fucking rub it out twice,
rub one out twice before I can go to work.
If you feel in a week.
And then I would just,
I would be friendly tour and then that's it.
And just wait until it's like you playing poker here.
Eventually she,
as long as you're nice to her.
Okay.
She can't get mad at you.
All she could do was get frustrated and eventually she,
she might get so frustrated that she just gives up or she puts the cards on the
table when she puts her cards on the table.
You just say how much you like,
first of all,
she's married and then just talk about how much you like her husband and how
much you respect them and what a great guy he is.
You know,
and then the g and then this is the big thing.
Don't judge her either.
Okay.
Like
how George Bush didn't rub it in the fucking noses of the Russians.
Just let the wall come down.
The big thing in something like that is you is to give her a dignified out.
Not saying she deserves one.
I'm saying this for you.
If you give her a dignified out where she can feel she can walk away and not be
embarrassed to Sam,
totally flattered.
If you weren't married,
I absolutely would not to mention I,
you know,
I think your husband's a great guy and he's been great to me,
so I,
I can't.
Okay.
And
Yeah,
yeah,
that's,
you know,
and I would just,
something like that and then just,
just,
you know,
hopefully if fucking goes away,
but I do find it funny with all of this abusive power and all of this shit,
you know,
and I don't think your situation is fucking unique.
Um,
it's just that nobody cares to hear it.
So I'm glad you put it on this podcast because,
uh,
you know,
I give a shit.
Good luck buddy.
That's a tough one.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
Please listen to Jim and Sam today and,
uh,
or listened to the replay if you missed it.
Chuck,
we out on Seth Meyers tomorrow and you can also listen to me on Conan O'brien
needs a friend podcast on Earwolf.
And um,
and by the way,
uh,
this is,
I think this is the last couple of days.
She can stream poverty special on comedy central.com for free.
So,
uh,
definitely check it out.
And Paul broke all their streaming records.
I'm so proud of them and,
uh,
he's got some dates coming up,
so check that out,
check out his new hour.
It's fucking killer,
man.
All right,
that's it.
Uh,
I'll check it on your,
on Thursday.